[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm cabbie HD here
and one of the hardest things for me to
do is not immediately share my
experience with a new piece of tech but
I did it anyway today is from when
you're watching this a couple weeks ago
and this is the iPhone 6s plus so I'm
not dropping my full review of this guy
on day one but that is actually coming
very soon but in the meantime this is I
guess your first unboxing from a couple
days ago and my first impressions
[Applause]
[Music]
so at the end of the day there are three
main differences need to know about
between this iPhone 6s and 6s plus vs.
last year's iPhone 6 and 6 plus and
that's the new camera new specs and the
new display the new camera is simple
enough new 12 megapixel shooter now
capable of crisp your photos and 4k
video which I of course enabled first
thing when I got it and with the iPhone
6s plus they also get optical image
stabilization which should help with
overall Chris penis video and low-light
shooting a lot my initial impressions of
this camera are wow this thing is fast
and the photos it takes look very
natural very true to life often with
very warm tones not only will I cover
this whole camera in depth in the full
review but once we get the new Nexus I
think we're due for a best smartphone
camera shootout and this one seems like
it'll be right up there with the best
the new specs were already announced at
the event but there was that lingering
question of how much RAM this new phone
had exactly so of course I've fired up
Geekbench to test that out the new a9
chip of course did very well on the
benchmark itself if you care about that
kind of thing and the app also verified
that we do in fact have two EAGA bytes
of RAM on the new iPhone overall
performance so far has been very snappy
and you'd expect that with iOS fresh
install of iOS 9 and I've been getting
used to some of its new features most of
which being forced touch or 3d touch the
new pressure-sensitive display so far a
few of apple's apps are really the ones
that are really best taking advantage of
it
but I fully expect third-party
developers to get on this quick and
start building in 3d touch functionality
into their own apps so it'll only be a
matter of time before everyone's getting
their new iPhones and everyone's
learning how and when to force touch or
3d touch over the next few weeks so
anyway yeah now you know I've been using
the new iPhone for the past couple weeks
and I'm nearly ready to post my full
review by the time you watch this video
so that's coming soon be sure to
subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already to be one of the first to see
that and also follow on Twitter since
I'm now able to actually post day-to-day
stuff like the battery life I'm getting
and the photos I'm taking on this camera
so follow there if you haven't and
that's pretty much it thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next one bass